la taille d'un grain de sable de
fentanyl de voiture peut en fait tuer une personne des enfants des
adultes ils en meurent des
utilisateurs ponctuels
euh
vous n'avez pas besoin d'être un toxicomane il y a une
stigmatisation
[Musique]
votre problème
[  Musique]
tout allait bien et puis elle a
commencé à travailler pendant l'été à 15 ans. j'ai
rencontré des personnes
que j'ai découvertes en décembre qui
lui avaient présenté des analgésiques
euh Xanax ou Percocet Je ne sais pas quelle
[Musique]
vous pensez que vous  vous prenez du Xanax ou vous
pensez que vous prenez du Percocet, mais en
fait, vous prenez
cela avec du fentanyl ou vous n'en
recevez pas du tout et vous prenez du
fentanyl pur, c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
empoisonné par cela parce que vous  je ne sais pas
que c'est ce que vous obtenez
étranger
[Musique]
mon fils
était dans sa chambre pendant le dimanche du Super Bowl
et nous pensions tous que tout le monde était en
sécurité et installé à la maison
et nous sommes entrés environ une heure après
l'avoir nourri et avons trouvé  il est mort par
terre
[Music]
merci
d'accord, donc il y avait un trafiquant de drogue sur
Snapchat qui a tendu la main à notre fils avec
un menu de drogue coloré avec euh des images
et des couleurs et en bas il était dit
qu'il avait livré et ainsi
euh, il s'est connecté avec notre fils et
a livré les médicaments à notre domicile après que nous nous
soyons endormis
sans savoir qu'ils croient que la pilule a une
assurance de contrôle de la qualité, elle a été fabriquée en
laboratoire, il y avait un scientifique ou
des chimistes qui surveillaient une facture de producteur
dans laquelle elle était intégrée afin que la stigmatisation
liée à la consommation d'héroïne ne soit pas liée
à la forme de la pilule
[Musique]
aux États-Unis  il y a eu une grande poussée pendant
des années pour mieux gérer la douleur et la traiter
comme le cinquième signe vital et cette
pensée que la prescription d'opioïdes pour la
douleur chronique à long terme peut être utile,
mais en effet, il est très clair que c'est
très nocif et que nous avons créé  cette
demande du marché pour les opioïdes
étrangers
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]